[Music]
welcome back to CBS mornings where we
are learning more about a hidden threat
to our waterways and our health
so-called forever chemicals have been
widely used for decades in product like
cookware cosmetics and food packaging
and they have since leached into our
water and can be found in the blood of
most Americans these chemicals have
already been linked to a range of health
problems including some forms of cancer
Roxanna severi looks now at what's being
done in an effort to protect us
on a Hilltop in Maine
Songbird Farm sits silently
a shell of what it was and could have
been welcome to the ghost town of our
dreams
Nordell and his wife Johanna bought the
40 acres and 20
raise organ produce and a family
seven years later they learned their
land was riddled with toxic chemicals
called pfas did you know what pfas were
no no no no I didn't know what what PFS
chemicals were he soon found out they're
a family of thousands of compounds that
last so long in the environment they're
known as forever chemicals for decades
they've been widely used to put the
non-stick in cookware and to make stain
and waterproof Fabrics firefighting foam
food packaging even Cosmetics the toxins
at Songbird Farm were traced to sludge
the solids left after Wastewater is
treated spread there as fertilizer in
the 1990s it contained a whole host of
industrial chemicals that were washing
out of consumer products in people's
homes or that we're entering the
wastewater treatment district from
industrial facilities
Adam says tests found their water and
some crops had dangerously high levels
so did his family's blood he says it was
250 times higher than average living
with pfast exposure is terrifying I feel
like I have a poorly wired Time Bomb
inside of me that's because pfas have
been linked to health problems like low
birth weight liver damage and some kinds
of cancer while Maine is leading the way
in identifying Farmland contaminated
with pfas a recent study estimates that
sludge like what was applied here has
also been spread on around 5 percent of
all Farmland in this country
while not all sludge contains toxins
cattle that ate feed grown in tainted
soil have been destroyed in at least
three states the chemicals also leech
into lakes rivers and groundwater from
factories and landfills they've really
contaminated fish everywhere
climatologists Anne Brown showed us a
stretch of a river near Detroit where
the fish are too contaminated to eat I
just can't imagine that there's any
place that's going to be truly safe from
pfaz at this point a recent analysis of
freshwater fish samples collected by the
EPA found pifas are an issue in almost
every state they're so pervasive Studies
have shown more than 95 percent of
Americans now have detectable levels in
their blood and now for the first time
the EPA is proposing strict regulations
limiting pfas in drinking water more
than 90 percent lower than previous
recommended levels I was very pleased to
see this Elsie Sunderland studies pfas
pollution at her Harvard University lab
how would you characterize the federal
government's approach toward pfas I
would call it ambitious yet fragmented
you know if if we're really concerned
about pfas and our everyday exposure we
should be proactive and we should should
be banning these chemicals from
non-essential uses in an email to CBS
News the FDA says it tests products in
the u.s's general food supply which is
among the safest in the world the agency
says very few of those products have
detectable levels of pfas and those that
do are low in this greenhouse we hear
tomatoes in the summer and spinach and
head lettuce in the winter back in Maine
Adam has turned from working on his farm
to pushing for new laws to help other
Farmers with dreams spoiled by forever
chemicals if I can help protect other
people from what happened to me
that motivates me to get up and go to
work every day for CBS mornings Roxanna
saberi Unity Maine